what's interesting if you take a look at
pricing in the Northeast not every price
metric there is depressed talk us
through what's the worst pricing metric
there and what's not as bad and closer
to henry hub right so when you think of
the Appalachia area think of the
northeast Marcellus and think of the
southwestern section of the Marcellus in
the Northeast they continue to be
capacity constraint so think of lighty
for example pricing their wide basis
differentials pricing there closer to a
dollar a dollar fifty there are some
areas like the New York hubs where
pricing is much more sufficient but in
general if you take into account lady
Dominion dominions south there is a
constraint there so basis is wide in
other areas basis is not as widening it
is closer to the Henry Hub price but in
general if you take a look at the
broader northeast the broader Marcellus
you will continue to have these
intermittent why pricing differentials
because of this imbalance this
structural secular shift of significant
capacity relative to the cyclical
seasonal demand needs within the area I
love it differentials good stud